bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors on va dans quelques
instants être en direct pour suivre
l'allocution du chef de l'état mais tout
d'abord qu'est ce que vous attendiez de
cette visite des manuels macro
absolument rien cette visite c'est de la
com ils feraient mieux travailler au
lieu de faire de la communication
on a un véritable village potemkine
cette école ne ressent pas la réalité
on a sept élèves parfait sages comme des
images figées qui écoutent ou qui ne
sont presque pas de vrais élèves
concrètement tout a été mise en scène
c'est absolument ridicule
le but n'est pas de rassurer les gens
mais d'avoir un langage de vérité comme
edouard philippe l'a dit cette reprise
c'est un pari risqué
pourquoi faire un pari risqué pourquoi
mettre en danger les familles les élèves
les enseignants les personnels
d'éducation alors qu'on devrait tous se
reprendre en septembre sereinement et
continuer à faire cours à distance
s'éroder jusqu'à début juillet comme
prévu il n'y a aucune urgence à faire
cela on comprend pas cette précipitation
et cette soumission à l'économie à paris
risque est justement pour des raisons
économiques pour permettre à des gens de
retravailler mais il nous pourrons par
travailler puisque toute façon les colts
en alternance il ya beaucoup
d'aberrations en fait là dedans on nous
explique que les parents pour tourner
travail et non s'ils ont deux enfants
alain et en cours l'autre non ils
devront garder ou pas pas différemment
d'habitude si les deux sont seulement à
l'école un jour sur deux une demi
journée par semaine une semaine sur deux
ils ne pourront pas retourner travailler
donc il faudra qu'ils continuent à
travailler à la maison de toute façon
ils pourront peut-être aller travailler
quelques fois sur leur lieu de travail
mais pas plus donc en plus c'est de
l'enfumage
il ya vraiment à côté gare de rennes on
dénonce depuis un an et demi chez les
stylos rouges
cet aspect garderie de l'école nous ne
sommes pas une garderie nous sommes des
enseignants nous faisons court et on
fera mieux cours à distance que en
classe avec ce protocole aberrant de 56
pages en primaire pour que les garanties
sanitaires soient respectées elles ne le
seront pas toutes façons c'est une
évidence en particulier en zone rouge
on comprend absolument pas qui d'une
différence de fait entre collèges
le primaire sur ces zones puisque zone
rouge égale zone dangereuse
donc elle n'est pas dangereuse seulement
pour les collégiens ou des lycéens elle
est dangereuse pour tout le monde
ou pourquoi les écoles rouvrent hôtels
et on est très heureux d'avoir été
entendu par les maires les élus locaux
en général on les avait appelés dans
notre communiqué à ne pas rouvrir les
écoles et on est très heureux d'entendre
que beaucoup répondre favorablement à
notre demande par logique par raison il
faut être rationnel en fait on parle de
la santé des gens on n'est pas dans la
politique ou dans l'idéologie le
gouverneur lui edouard philippe qui qui
était donc hier devant le sénat pour
défendre ses mesures de déconfinement a
parlé d'un décrochage scolaire pour
certains élèves ont une véritable bombe
à retardement donc il était impératif
que certains élèves reprennent le chemin
de l'école
est ce que ça vous l'entendez justement
que certains élèves voilà pourrait avoir
de grosses difficultés dans l'avenir
alors c'est quand même merveilleux que
le gouvernement et monsieur blanc caire
comprennent qu'il ya des des faucheurs
il y en a toujours eu et on aura deux
mains et on a aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas
les décrocheurs qui vont revenir à
l'école on voit encore que cette reprise
des cours est faite par des technocrates
complètement déconnectés du terrain
les mesures ne sont pas applicables ils
ne le savent pas parce qu'ils ne savent
pas ce qu'est une école la seule école
qu'il connaisse c'est celle où ils
étaient quand il était enfant
donc ça fait loin et ça fait peu pour ce
qui est des décrocheurs non ils ne
reviendront pas ce ne sont pas eux qui
vont revenir
donc ça ne changera rien au décrochage
et est-ce qu'on va risquer la santé de
la population française en général des
enseignants personnels de santé par en
famille avant fanfan pour 5%
qu'est ce que c'est que cette logique on
va sacrifier à 5% décrocheurs l'ensemble
de la population
c'est débile c'est inepte c'est
inconséquent et inconscient le
gouvernement est stupide de partir sur
ce principe
et en plus c'est un argument cynique
c'est à dire qu'ils utilisent les
décrocheurs pour faire passer leurs
mesures
inepte donc c'est d'autant plus
scandaleux on le dénonce clairement chez
les styles rouge voilà volontariat pour
les élèves mais pas pour les profs
pourquoi cissé volontariat c'est qu'il
ya un danger
on ne comprend pas voilà on nous on
aimerait que la reprise soit en
septembre on le demande c'est pas qu'on
aimerait c'est qu'elle doit être faite
en septembre et qu'on laisse les cours à
distance
comme ils sont actuellement pour les
décrocheurs on fait comme on peut mais
comme d'habitude je dirais c'est pas
différent encore une fois aujourd'hui
hier demain les décrocheurs sont les
décrocheurs ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faut rien faire on va pas sacrifier le
pays pour eux mais psychologiquement
pour les élèves qui sont maintenant
voilà depuis pratiquement deux mois
voilà loin de l'école si on poursuit
voilà ce confinement en tout cas pas de
reprise comme vous le dites pour les
élèves avant septembre cela va faire
beaucoup trop temps ils ont perdu le
contact avec leurs camarades parfois
l'école mais peut-être aussi un moyen de
survie pour certains élèves qui où
certains enfants qui se retrouvent
confinés dans des petits dans des petits
appartements parisiens par exemple
complètement sa cerveau longtemps je
veux dire c'est difficile pour tout le
monde
les collègues qui sont dans un studio
par exemple à paris c'est pareil pour
avancer difficile c'est difficile pour
tout le monde le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas le choix
la question ne se pose pas en
psychologiquement c'est dur ou pas c'est
difficile notamment pour des petits mais
c'est comme ça qu'est ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse on va pas plier la réalité à
de l'idéologie ou à des désirs le
problème c'est que c'est dangereux de
reprendre que les petits ne seront pas
adopter les gestes barrières que les
écoles ne pourront pas garantir la
sécurité des personnels des enfants et
de leurs familles
c'est la monnaie c'est un discours de
vérité qu'il faut tenir les pays qui ont
décidé de rouvrir leur école japon
allemagne aussi retourne en arrière
puisque les cas explose donc est ce que
c'est ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on veut
que les cas explose et dans trois 3
semaines par exemple se retrouvaient
tous de nouveaux confiné à cause de
cette décision débile et précipité
raisonnable les mesures barrières les
gestes que l'on voit là que l'on demande
aux enfants d'effectuer on parle aussi
voilà du port de masque obligatoire
selon certains à carreaux tout cas
pendant la cour de récréation les repas
qui devrait être prise en classe toutes
ces mesures qui sont voilà cent c'est un
petit peu aidé à ce retour scolaire nous
vous ça ne vous satisfait pas cette
viable selon vous c'est pas applicable
on parlait psychologie vous utilisiez le
le mot psychologie pour la souffrance
que les enfants peuvent réellement
ressentir en étant confiné
imaginez des petits séquestrée dans leur
salle de cours et même y manger mais
c'est aberrant encore une fois ça a été
fait par des technocrates déconnecté où
on ne comprend pas comment ça va se
passer
nous on invite les inspecteurs notamment
à le faire à notre place pendant
quelques temps ils nous montrent ils
nous donnent l'exemple
il nous faut une belle opération de com
ils nourrissent les enfants en classe
ils leur font cours
et puis on verra après quand ils nous
ont donné l'exemple parce qu'on a
entendu dire beaucoup la danse chez les
stylos rouges beaucoup de pression
d'intimidation de menaces sont faites
par les inspecteurs notamment du premier
degré ces gens complètement déconnectés
du terrain qui infantilise les collègues
de primaire les profs des écoles pour
leur dire qu'ils doivent reprendre qu'il
faut qu'il le fasse qui leur met une
pression d'un qui leur disent qu'ils
devront faire plus d'heures plus
travaillé que d'habitude sans aucune
compensation comme d'habitude
culpabilisation menace c'est le
l'habituel on va dire du fonctionnement
de l'éducation nationale en particulier
en primaire on infantilise les
enseignements on a tellement l'habitude
de gérer des enfants qu'on infantilise
des adultes et là ça ressort de manière
vraiment flagrante est très inquiétante
donc nous on agite vraiment les
collègues d'école primaire à ne pas se
laisser faire
le droit de retrait est une possibilité
réelle si on les oblige à venir qu'il
vienne qu'il constate que les choses ne
peuvent pas fonctionner sont dangereuses
la sécurité n'est pas garantie qui le
note dans le registre chsct avant
qu'indique problèmes d'hygiène et
sécurité et qu'ils partent qu'ils
fassent valoir leur droit de retrait il
n'y a aucune raison de risquer sa santé
celle des autres pour une lubie
ministériel alors il n'y a pas
d'obligation pour les parents de
remettre leurs enfants à l'école
on parle le gouvernement appelle à la
responsabilité citoyenne c'est à chaque
parent de décider mais qu'en est-il
justement des enseignants est ce que
vous serez obligé de reprendre justement
le chemin de l'école déconfinement leurs
11 mai alors en primaire tout à fait a
priori c'est obligatoire vous dit il ya
énormément de pression à ce sujet là
reste que vu que le gouvernement patine
complètement passe son temps à dire une
chose sd dire que dès que monsieur blanc
qu'elle ouvre la bouche il est désavoué
par monsieur macro monsieur philippe
alors on ne sait pas trop
en fait les mairies comme vous aidiez
nous suivent beaucoup dans l'idée de ne
pas réouvrir les écoles primaires le 11
mai ou à partir du 11 mai donc on ne
sait pas pour l'instant à quelle sauce
on va être mangé et c'est très compliqué
je salue aussi le rôle des directeurs
d'école qui doivent gérer cette reprise
et qui ne savent pas où ils vont
concrètement c'est très difficile pour
eux ils doivent envisager cette reprise
mais ils ne savent pas comment elle se
fera et puis niveau responsabilité
pénale
beaucoup de gens le disent un peu
partout nos collègues des syndicats on
l'entend bon nicolas guyart je vais vous
demander de rester avec nous on va tout
de suite prendre en direct la direction
des yvelines a pour écouter le chef de
l'état emmanuel on vient donc d'entendre
un emmanuel macron le chef de l'état
souhaite que tous les enfants qui ont
besoin de revenir à l'école puissent le
faire
il a justement parlé de ce traumatisme
voilà pour les enfants de rester trop
longtemps loin de l'école qu'avez vous
retenu
voilà de ces mots du chef de l'état
alors j'en ai vécu pas mal de choses
déjà je salue son propos et je rebondis
il a dit qu'il fallait éviter le
brassage l'école c'est le lieu du
brassage des millions d'enfants vont se
retrouver de nouveau en contact des
millions les élèves de france des
millions donc ils vont se retrouver en
contact pouvoir se refiler tous les
virus qui vont passer puisque étant
confiné il n'était pas en contact donc
là les virus vont circuler pas seulement
de covin d'ailleurs donc tout le monde
va tomber malade ça va être super les
adultes aussi au passage et puis tout le
monde va se refiler ça dans tous les
sens le cosy de aussi donc je enfin
voilà donc je suis des sports est
appelée de brassage il parlait justement
des français qui
qui ont des proches qui ont de la
famille d'aller beaucoup trop loin alors
que là on
parlant des écoles précisément on sait
que les classes vont être très
restreinte
chaque maire d'ailleurs va décider quels
sont les élèves qui vont revenir il doit
se mettre en accord avec les directeurs
d'école pour privilégier ceux qui ont
des difficultés scolaires dont le nombre
d'élèves qui seront présents à partir du
11 12 13 mai sera assez restreint tout
de même alors il serait restreint par
rapport à la normale mais il ne sera pas
restera par rapport à la situation
actuelle
on aura entre la volonté de jean michel
bancaire c'était à peu près 50% de plus
60% de plus en plus verser c'est à peu
près 40% des élèves habituel au total
donc c'est énorme
il ya 12 millions d'élèves en france
vous prenez 40% ça allait quand même pas
mal ça fait des millions donc de toute
façon ça va se brasser les gestes
barrière ne pourront pas être respectées
notamment pour les plus petits ça va se
redresser
on va tous se refiler tout et n'importe
quoi le co lead en particulier donc oui
le brassage va se faire ce brassage non
voulues lorsque les gens se déplacent à
plus de 100 km il aura lieu en fait au
sein des villes d'où au sein de leurs
écoles qui vont être de vrais
laboratoire de deux virus quoi
concrètement nous moi ce que je retiens
aussi c'est qu'on mette des cobayes
concrètement on va voir comment ça se
passe alors on remet les profs dans les
écoles remet les personnels on regarde
ce que ça donne sur les enfants les
parents auraient pu on avisera après
mais c'est complètement irresponsable sa
des enseignants et des élèves à qui sont
dans des écoles
la preuve sur tes épaules cette école
dont il est question aujourd'hui et où
se trouve le président de la république
est restée ouverte pendant le
confinement à la queue y est justement
les élèves
voilà deux de ceux qui étaient obligés
de travailler notamment le personnel
soignant
on n'a pas eu vraiment de retour
concernant cette cette période donc il
ya déjà eu ce test entre guillemets
pendant cette période de confinement
avec ses élèves et ses enseignants mais
il faut mon c'est à dire un très petit
nombre il y en aura forcément plus donc
les risques vont être plus grand est ce
que le risque en vaut la chandelle
c'est ça que je veux dire les
décrocheurs je l' ai déjà dit je le
répète ne reviendront pas pour une
immense majorité le principe même d'un
élèves décrocheurs c'est que la famille
n'arrive pas à suivre la famille ne le
tiens pas parfois il ne viendra pas plus
à l'école qu'avant alors imaginez pour
des lycéens par exemple vous croyez que
fin mai début juin ils vont revenir
blessé
c'est complètement stupide c'est ne pas
connaître le terrain et puis pour aussi
les enfants victimes de violence à la
maison alors c'est horrible il faut
lutter contre ça il faut que la police
notamment les services sociaux agissent
à ce sujet là le problème est entier
n'empêche que c'est pas en revenant à
l'école qui aura moins de violence je
veux dire pour les vacances d'été est ce
que les violences cessent banon les
enfants sont toujours au milieu de leur
famille c'est peut-être là où est le
problème
le soir quand il entre à la maison les
violences ces stèles non s'ils sont à
l'école un jour sur deux ils seront quoi
violente à jour sur deux c'est horrible
enfin ça ne change rien ce sont des faux
argument c'est du pathos ont fait
emmanuel macron manie le pathos
d'ailleurs il n'a rien dit il n'y a rien
de pragmatique il n'a pas parlé de
masques il n'a pas parlé de test ils ont
détruit nos moyens de nous défendre avec
des masques en euros
on les vendant en détruisant l'hôpital
public là il n'a rien dit de concret sur
les garanties nécessaires il dit qu'il
ne veut pas mettre les profonds dont
j'ai par exemple
mais quels moyens on ne mettra jamais en
situation de danger
il y aura un dialogue permanent voilà
entre les élus et les professeurs et les
si les conditions ne sont pas remplies
rond va pas vous obliger à retourner à
l'école il a aussi salué
voilà le courage et peut-être les
enseignants le travail des enseignants
pendant cette période de confinement
d'enseigner
ligne oui alors le fait qu'ils nous et
c'est à lui et c'est de la stratégie
c'est de la com parce qu'il sent qu'il
ya une grosse grenouille enseignants qui
n'en a pas besoin en ce moment puisque
la grogne sociale et couvent est là mais
elle est partout on la voit sur les
réseaux sociaux la voix dont dans tous
les domaines quasiment d'activité donc
je le remercie bien de sa petite pensée
pour nous mais enfin pensez à nous c'est
aussi mieux nous payer mieux nous
traiter mieux gérer l'école en général
en amont après préparer un monde d'après
où l'école soit enfin respectée
l'hôpital évidemment aussi les
transports aussi la fonction publique en
général ou et dont il ya que du blabla
il n'y a rien eu de concret il part dans
son pathos il parlant du lyrique comme
d'habitude le concret c'est quoi c'est
qu'on n'a aucune garantie fiable pour
savoir si on ne va pas être mis en
danger pour relancer l'économie
les collections sont super contents
d'entendre qu'ils ne les mettra pas en
danger ce ne sont que des mots imposer
le retour en classe des preuves
puisqu'il quand il dit qu'il ne
l'obligeant à personne à être en danger
il ne dit pas qu'il n'oubliera pas les
enseignants retournent en classe ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose
ça n'a rien à voir sac signé une
directive qui dit qu'on doit retourner à
l'école on doit retourner en cours en
présentiel
ben on devra bien y aller ou alors faire
valoir un droit de retrait mais ça va
être compliqué parce que le gouvernement
tirera fera tout pour dire que nous
n'avons pas à le faire valoir à leur
terme vous parliez du porte du mas vous
parlez également des tests on sait que
ça sera au maire d'organiser ce retour
scolaire ce retour de à l'école ils
auront donc cette responsabilité anne
hidalgo s'est exprimé à ce sujet est là
elle a déclaré d'ailleurs que les
enfants pourraient justement avoir
recours à des tests pourraient faire des
tests à leur retour
à l'école qu'en pensez vous est-ce que
justement les maires devraient prendre
le modèle de la mère de paris alors tous
les maires n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
que la mairie de paris
c'est ma mairie donc voilà mais je la
mairie de paris à des moyens que les
autres n'ont absolument pas et mettre
sur le dos des directeurs dès qu elles
des chefs d'établissement des
enseignants des maires des collectivités
locales la responsabilité de sécurité
qui est celle de l'état est une honte
encore une fois c'est un moyen de se
dédouaner on a en un gouvernement qui ne
sait plus quoi faire mais qu'il qu'il
soit logique ils ne veulent pas de
brassage on veut la sécurité pour tous
on reprend en septembre on continue les
cours en ligne ça se passe globalement
bien c'est mieux que rien c'est ça que
j'aimerais faire comprendre c'est mieux
que rien il n'y a pas d'urgence à
reprendre en présentiel
ça serait mieux j'aimerais revoir mes
élèves il me manque réellement mais ce
n'est pas viable ce n'est pas fiable
il n'y a aucune garantie donc il faut il
faut vraiment être raisonnable là dessus
et on n'a rien de raisonnable dans ce
qui nous a été dit ensuite je voulais
réagir aussi sur la journée de
prérentrée nombre d'établissements
prévoient leurs 11 mai par exemple 18
parfois au collège une journée de
prérentrée
mais c'est d'une débilité absolue la
réunion de pré rentrée c'est on va on va
mettre c'est tous les adultes d'un
établissement ou presque ensemble pareil
ils vont se refiler des gastro entérites
des grippes locaux vides ont
tranquillement pour quelque chose de
complètement inutiles qui peut être
faire en visioconférence ou l'approuver
on n'arrête pas de faire des réunions
visio et puis d'ailleurs on fait moins
de l'habitude qui prouve qu'elles ne
servent à rien la plupart du temps nous
le dira quel est l'intérêt de réunir des
adultes le 11 mai pour qu'ils se rendent
tous malades pour expliquer qu'il faut
mettre des masques et se laver les mains
enfin des wc prendre les adultes pour
des débiles ce que les gestes barrières
sont quand même pas très bien qui a
respecté pour des adultes pour des
enfants c'est autre chose
vous pouvez leur raconter comme annuel
emmanuel macron le faisait ce matin à
poissy à des gamins figé sages comme des
images pas caractéristique de ce qu'est
une école et une classe même en petit
nombre d'ailleurs vous pouvez leur dire
il faut te laver les mains il faut pas
s'approcher des gens si tu as un masque
et que tu le touches il faut que tu te
lave les mains derrière un enfant ne le
fera pas systématiquement et c'est
normal ou bien c'est la lumière
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne
donc voilà aux propos du chef de l'état
qui a répondu aux questions des
journalistes